各位听众朋友们大家好，欢迎回到Photo Reason新一期的节目。
这是一档贩摄影谈话类节目。
我们希望摆脱故作高深的艺术术语，不做求真求智的教科书，只想和大家聊聊有关摄影的一切。
那今天这期节目将由我和塞文一起和大家聊聊手机摄影这个话题。
先请塞文跟大家打个招呼。
Hello 大家好，我是塞文。
嗯，大家好。那今天为什么要开启这个话题呢？
因为首先塞文算是我们这个团队里面用手机拍照时间最长也拍的最好的一位主播。
然后去年还获得了小米新经典的奖项。
主要是你们都不怎么用啊，就只有我才拍。
所以我是拍的最好的。
然后今年呢，我们也跟小米有一个社群共创的这样的一个计划已经选出了三位的听友来参加手机的使用和拍摄。
那我就想说，哎，那不如我也把之前小米给我的这个14 Ultra捡起来用用。
就不要让他吃灰嘛。
我也确实看到了很多很出彩的照片。
那我就想说，那我也用手机看看我能拍出些什么样的照片。
然后我也想看看手机的一个上线它在哪里。
对，因为我们今年上半年的时候要做一个一系列的就是关于手机摄影的一个话题。
这次的机会可以把它作为我们这个手机摄影系列的第一期。
然后我们可能就着重的去聊一聊，就是我们作为两种不同的角色。
我呢，其实是一直在用手机，包括之前用iPhone也在拍照。
然后后面在用小米之后也拍了很多的照片。
而白熊呢，其实是好像据我所知是并没有用手机拍照的习惯对吧。
嗯，拍的不多，偶尔有偶尔也会有，但真的没有塞纹度。
对，我可能就是一直都在用手机请你拍照。
所以说，我们其实也想看一看，就是说我们使用程度不一样的两个人。
我们看能聊一聊对这个手机摄影的一些看法，
还有说我们的一些使用上啊，或者对它能创作出是什么东西的一些看法。
但据我所知，好像你之前获得一台小米的手机，很早之前对不对。
对，24年的时候吧，好像。
因为我当时我没有小米，你拿到了之后，我还拿来用了一段时间，觉得还挺好用的当时就。
但是好像自那之后，你就就好像没有再继续用小米或者继续用手机拍照的，是因为什么原因呢？
那据我之前用手机，就是iPhone手机也会偶尔拍一些照片，只是我发的不太多。
我也没有成体系成习惯性的去用手机进行创作啊拍照。
纯粹就是瞎玩，然后我觉得阻碍我说用小米手机的一个因素就是我习惯出门就带一个手机了。
我觉得带两台手机会让我一个手拿一个手机，一个手兜里还要再揣一个。
感觉上掏出掏近不是很方便，所以我觉得这个是一个很大的因素。
我觉得如果说听诱里面它本身就是一个安卓机的用户，
那我觉得现在的安卓机确实在摄影方面都挺好的，不管是OPPO还是小米还是其他的。
那你其实也要带相机出面，你其实平常拍照片拍的很多，
但你就是觉得多带一个手机你会觉得是雷锥，
但是你多背一个大的相机，你会觉得没有什么问题，是不是？
对，这个问题我也觉得很有趣，就是相机你有相机肩带，
你可以背在鞋跨在肩膀上，有时候就可以解放双手。
那有时候手机你要一只手如果拿了iPhone，另一只手还要再拿一台手机，
你就会觉得两个手就在打架，就腾不出第三只手来做事情了，对。
我想可能还有一部分原因就是因为苹果手机也好，
还有就是和另外一台手机，小米也好或者其他的，
它其实他们有非常多的功能是重复的，在形态上对吧？
对，形态上还有功能上是很多重复的，对。
然后如果说你只是把比如说另外一套手机当作我拍照的一个工具，
我觉得这是可以的，如果说你带的都是两个手机，他们都有很多相同的功能，
那你还要可能用微信啊用其他的，那会觉得你确实挺烦的。
那你呢？
我其实是属于平常就是相机再加两台手机的状态，
而且我会发现我从去年开始，然后手机拍的照片会比相机多很多，
我觉得这方面，这改变其实一方面是我对手机拍照的一个定位就是。
我是随时随地都在拍照的，我就是我随时随地都在观察，我一直在观察，
所以我看到我感兴趣的东西我就会把它记录下来，
那么这个时候手机的便利性就体现出来了，
所以我就会拿起手机把我感兴趣的东西拍下来，
而我对相机的一个界定可能是说，我现在更希望或者是说更把相机作为一个创作的工具，
所以我只是要带入到我正在创作或者是我有一个明确的创作目的的时候，
比如说我这次带了相机，也带了手机去新疆，
我虽然都在拍，但是两个拍的东西是不一样的，
就手机就是我任何我去哪里玩，或者去参加什么东西，好玩的东西我都记录下来了，
而相机就相对来说，它就是在我进入到创作状态的时候，
我才会一直用相机，但其实也很难说我两个一起用的时候，
其实会再用一个你会忘了另外一个，
就是我用相机拍到的时候我就很难想起来用手机去拍，
对，人就一个脑子嘛，
因为我觉得这两者的话他们在拍摄的习惯或者是思考上面也是不一样的，
有的时候就手机纯粹为了记录，
我看到一个有意思的东西，我可能就以过去非常快的把拍下来了，
我这次去新疆，包括之前在大理的时候，
我有的时候会骑电动车或者摩托车，
我骑摩托车的时候，
即便你把那个相机背在身上，
但是你就临时停一下，你会发现是比较限制的，
除非是看到一个很吸引的画面，你就想用相机把它拍下来，
我可能会把，我要先停车，吸火，然后把相机拍出来，
然后再走到面前，选号勾渡拍一张，
而如果我只是作为记录的话，我只需要停个车，
脚撑在地上，我甚至都不需要吸火，
我就掏出手机，拿到一个合适的位置，我把它就拍出来了，
我其实去年拿小米莱卡影像经典奖的时候，
新经典奖的那张黑白照片，
就是孤独那张黑白照片，
其实就是在骑摩托车的时候停在而海边，
看到远处有几棵树，还有一个人，
然后我就拍下来了，
就这样随意拍下来，然后就获奖了？
对，但也不能随意拍，其实是观察，
就是它的整个拍照动作是很简单的，
但是更多还是观察，反正就这样拍下来的。
我觉得我开始重度使用手机拍照，
应该是从4月份，4月的清明节我去了山西，
我当时也是带了一台妈咪娅漆，
然后我也带上了小米，
然后在山西玩了四天左右的时间，
我在不拍胶片的时候，我就一直拿着小米手机，
我就想去体验说拿着手机拍照和胶片拍照，
到底有什么区别？
那有什么区别？
我觉得非常便捷的一个就是，
手机可以变胶，
就是因为我妈咪娅挂的是一个广角头，
你真的在看到远处有个东西，
你想放特别大的时候，
手机的优势就是体现出来了，
因为妈咪娅的镜头，
它是一个广角的范围，
相当于65毫米，相当于32左右等效捐化幅，
所以它就只能拍一个大的场景，
你但凡想拍一个很远的或者进出的一个小东西的时候，
你又觉得拍一些小东西用胶片好像太浪费了，
然后拍远的地方，你又不可能就跑过去拍，
所以这个时候掏出手机，
把它摁到两倍或者三倍的时候，
确实很方便。
我可以理解为，
它其实可以作为一种视角的补充，
尤其像你也是长期拍胶片的，
有些照片确实，
胶片它就是一次快门，就是成本，
那我有些照片，
你并不确定你是不是需要用胶片拍，
或者你觉得可能不太适合用胶片拍，
或者拍照的状态，
我即便用数码，
反正我其实按快门还是相对来说比以前情深很多，
我去到一个地方的时候，
我会先拿起相机看一看，
然后看了之后，实时按不下去，
但是就觉得，
如果不拍会不会错过些什么，
然后掏出手机再拍一个，
特别是像麻米亚他一卷120，
他只能拍10张，
那我可能在一个场景，
就带两卷，就拍20张，
那你心里面总会是会有一些，
犹豫啊，或者说怕错过些什么，
然后小东西吧，
又觉得说拍胶片不划算，
所以这个时候手机确实可以做一个补充，
胶段的补充也好，
张数的补充也好，
然后后来我在4月底的时候又去了熊叶古道，
然后我这次就完全没有带数码相机，
没有带胶片相机，
然后我回忆了一下，
应该也是我第一次出门，
我们不带任何数码相机或者胶片相机，
就是唯一一次，
那你是为什么想做这件事情，
就是只得带一个手机出门，
就是我有一台比较轻便的胶片相机，
就是F80，它是塑料机身，
挂个镜头，
其实怎么说呢也就有一公斤左右，
但是因为我这次徒步，
我没有带行李，
所以就是一个背包，
那我想给自己一个清装的徒步的一个环境，
对有些户外老来说，
就是每一刻都是精打细算，
就是我看人家的视频多少重量，
对比较敏感的要重装的人来说，
都会刻刻的特别细致，
之前爬那个富士山，
我还带了两台相机，
但对我来说，
走到后面真的是非常的艰难，
那有人说你挂一个相机，
挂在肩上可能会晃来晃去嘛，
那我当时我爬富士山的时候，
我还买过一个肩带的挂扣，
你就把相机挂在肩带上，
其实那个时候也会好一点，
相机不会随着你走路会摇摆，
但它其实还是重量，
对就怎么说它还是一个重量，
是一个你不可忽视的体积上的重量，
和体积上的一个站位，
因为我这次在去日本就只有一个包，
我看到了，
这个也是我之前没有过的，
所以我就也想极致的追求一个清凉化的出行，
然后我也想试试看，
如果出行不带任何相机，
胶片机，数码相机，
这趟行程能拍些什么，
这是一个很大的一个好奇，
我想满足自己的好奇心。
首先一个，
你有拍到你自己觉得满意的照片吗？
每天的照片都挑不过来，
就是每天会按很多很多的快板？
很多很多，就比以前按的太多了，
这个是我前所未有的，
像以前我就可能算好，
我今天最多也就拍两到三卷，
第三卷可能都是背着的，
就不到万不得已，都不起用的胶卷，
然后这次我就是滑我的那个相册，
我就滑不完，太多了，
怎么能一下子按那么多快板，
我都没有想像过。
有人会说，
他说手机摄影其实是偷懒，
但是我在想，
你是一个比较特殊的例子，
因为你是从胶片切换到了手机摄影，
因为你从就相当于是一个，
有明显成本的一个拍照方式，
切换到一种免费，相当于免费的一种拍照方式。
有减入摄了，好吗？
对你来说，其实不是偷懒的，
反而是拍了很多很多，
可能其实一直都在拍照，
数量也很多，
而且就像我认识的有摄影师，
他们其实拍照的方式是喜欢用手机连拍的，
他会拍很多很多张，
然后在很多张里面，
而且有的手机也有那种连拍功能，
然后他从很多张里面去选，
然后就为了去抓某一个瞬间。
我也有，这次我也有。
当然你从拍照结果来看是拍了很多的照片，
那你从拍照的成果上面，
你个人觉得你是满意的吗？
还是说这次体验对你来说是感受什么样的？
我真的挺满意的，
我真的挺满意的。
首先真的是从重量上，
体积上对我来说就是一个很大的一个解放，
然后我一般徒步的时候，
就不太会再去看我苹果的手机，
我就把小米的手机，
就当做我的一个拍摄工具来拍。
这其实和我目前的一个使用方式也是一样的，
因为我自己也是以苹果手机，
一直在用苹果手机，
所以我的大部分照片，
以前拍照片都是苹果手机拍的，
存在iCloud上面，
后面切换到了，
就是拍照的时候我用小米去拍，
但是其实我会，
可能更多的还是把小米当做一个创作，
或者是拍照的工具，
它可能是一个比如说便携的口袋机，
而且这个口袋机其实比大多数的口袋机都强，
因为它可以变交，也有算法，
然后非常的方便。
我觉得这是比较好，
可能是比较适合我们这种人的一种创造方式，
就是当你想一个比较好的手机拍照，
因为大家都知道，
苹果的拍照功能不能说不好，
但是它确实现在不如国内的。
确实不太好。
你刚才说到一个便携相机，
因为我还有李光，
我在出发的时候其实还也纠结，
那我带他李光也可以，
因为李光跟小米其实也差不了太多，
都是便携性的，
李光也是正儿八经的一台数码相机，
那我也可以带李光，
但是因为也是考虑到说，
今年我们有这个社群的共创计划，
既然我们的听友也会用到手机，
那我也得来体验一下，
不然人家真的如果有什么想聊的东西，
那我可能就接不上话题了，
而且赛文也想做这一系列的专题，
我想总得也有个人也用一下手机，
来解一下心理的好奇，
我到底能用手机拍出来什么？
所以说这次拍照结果你也是非常满意，
非常满意，
据我所对你的了解，
就是你之前在拍照片的时候，
其实是非常喜欢照片的那种颜色，
然后在这方面你会有一些顾虑吗？
比如说这样照片，
如果用照片拍会多么多么的好，
但是你只带了手机，
会有这样的遗憾吗？
说实话一开始，
就是旅行的第一天是会有的，
我一直会想像说，
这个场景如果我用数码拍，
或者说我用照片拍，
我连它大概出片的一个什么样子，
什么结果其实心里都是有数的，
我心里会想着说，
如果我现在有照片相机，
我大概要怎么对，怎么测光，
我那套流程我都心里都在默念了，
但是反正都出来了，
有啥用啥，
然后套出手机就拍了，
但是我觉得从设备上的转化，
有一点很重要的，
就是你色彩上的一个敏感度，
它是你之前，
比如说你用过数码相机也好，
你用过照片机也好，
它会传承下来，
虽然你想用照片机，
但其实如果你用手机你一样能拍出，
大概一个你想要的一个结果，
我觉得这是一个帮助。
就相当于是一种个人的拍摄经验，
其实不管你用什么样的设备，
但是你的观察习惯在，
这种事物的敏感也是同样的，
所以说会拍的也大差不差。
只不过因为手机它有一个变焦的功能，
我觉得手机现在太强了，
尤其今年发的几个手机的旗舰版，
还配了外置的一个增具镜，
通过数码变焦，
然后能够达到400，
好像最多到1600，
是不是？
我觉得太夸张了，
很难想随身携带一个大炮，
像去新疆这样的地方天地很广阔，
如果你只是单纯的通过你的交通工具，
或者人去移动去改变你的构图的话，
其实是非常的局限的。
而且我觉得在心理负担上，
也给我做了很多减负，
因为以前带着相机，
总会有一种我要出片的这种心态，
就感觉今天要是拍不到什么好的照片，
就有一种哎呀，我好像白来的感觉。
但如果我拿着手机的话，
我会更专注在徒步这件事情上，
出去的那几天也是工作日，
然后手机上其实也会有一些工作消息，
那我就回得慢一点，
徒步的话，你的呼吸，你的心跳，
然后包括你走到那个古道里面的那些树，
那些鸟叫声，水的声音，
走路的时候，
这些听到的看到都会被无限的放大，
你会更轻松的去享受你走路的这个环境，
走路的这个当下，
如果说我带着相机的话，
我觉得反而会让我去分心，
我会想着说哎呀，
这个我要拍，那个我要拍，
熊越古道很大的一个魅力，
就是它能让你很好的跟自然有个连结，
让这种连结你会不太希望被一个东西去打破，
然后手机会显得很轻巧，
就是拍完又可以继续走，
然后数码相机总觉得说哎呀，
我要这里看看，那里看看，
对，所以心理负担其实也减轻了很多，
我没有抱着一个我要出片的这样的一个心态在这趟旅程中，
就是会心理上会放松很多，
然后你就更多的去注重在感受这件事情上，
是的,
而且我会觉得就是手机线的发展，
因为现在用手机的话，
我们几乎不需要去关注任何参数了，
不需要去关注你的ISO，快门啊这些东西，
你其实只需要拿起来，
全好角度构图就拍下去就可以了，
就是你其实这种决策成本，
还有包括你这种参数的，
它的一个操作成本其实降低了很多，
真正需要注意的就是你如何去构图，
你是怎样的视角去拍这个东西，
你就不需要去看这个ISO是多少，
它是否合适，快门是否合适，
因为都有算法，
它计算出来都会跟你，
有的为了让你能更好地去拍到一张好的照片，
它会通过算法，
比如说你的拍在运动的物体，
它可能会去选了一张最清晰的给你，
包括你拍的一些人物，
它会再通过一些算法，
会让它变得更准确吧。
但是有一点我在使用中，
我会觉得说，
手机会让这个画面过于明亮，
过于鲜艳，
可能是我设置问题，我不太清楚，
但是比如说鲜艳古道，
它因为树很高，
很多的时候它会遮蔽光线，
所以其实整个环境是比较幽暗的，
有时候手机一打开，
它会明显的你会感觉到，
它把周围的环境都体谅了，
我会经常性要按住之后，
把那个曝光往下降一点，
它才比较符合我眼睛看到的那个光线。
我觉得这可能就是手机，
它可能默认说，
哎呀，我要把环境体谅一点。
应该有一个快捷键，
你可以设置一个固定的曝光补偿，
现在都有。
这个可能就是我用的不太熟悉，
但是确实是有这种。
因为现在它可能也考虑到，
因为像侧光方式嘛，
我能感觉就是侧光方式的一些不一样，
然后它会默认把它拍得很亮，
然后可能要手动的去剪一些曝光，
是的,
而且这里就其实就说到一个手机拍摄的一个，
一个经验吧我觉得，
就是你在不管在白天的环境里面拍照，
还是说在除了夜晚啊，
你在很大多数场景里拍照吧，
不管你用什么手机，
即便你用的是苹果，
在拍照的时候，
适度的降低曝光，
它其实是会拍出来非常好的质感，
它会让你的照片的质感会有很高的提升，
这个这里面其实是我最近才发现的，
当我把曝光降了很多之后，
它会通过算法去识别画面里面亮的东西，
所以它会有一个算法优化的过程，
就是说你即便你感觉把曝光已经压到很低了，
好像很暗了，
但是你通过算法这一层之后，
它又会修复回来，
这样的话你这个曝光就相当于是，
你随便压了更低，
但是又恢复到正常，
它反而就是相对于提亮的画面当中的一个对比，
在一些场景下拍照照片的质感会非常的好，
这个大家可以试一试，
那么就我们正好就聊到说，
通过熊野古道也去了山西，
那么你有没有一些手机在你的旅行摄影当中的一些，
比如说使用方法、经验，
或者什么些可以分享一下？
我先说有一点，
就是我在走路的时候，
可能是我的口袋有它的想法，
它不小心把这个手机的画幅画面显示，
从4比3调成了16比9好像，
然后我突然发现，
这种比较瘦长的，
竖起来的画幅就很适合就古道里面的那种氛围，
因为它竖都是特别特别高的，
比值的那种场景，
我突然觉得这种16比9，
我平时基本都不会用到这种画幅就很适合，
你手机有自己的想法，
所以我就觉得说不同的这种画幅，
其实在不同的场景下也有自己特殊的一些运用，
但可能这种画幅在日常的话，
可能会不太适合了，
我可以说一下我自己拍照的一些拍摄，
包括选图修图的一些习惯，
其实我可能时候拍照的话，
我就是用的拍照模式，
拍照模式它有好处就是你的胶段可以更广，
小米它会分为专业模式和普通的拍照模式，
专业模式的话它其实更多，
就像是它把里面它算法隐藏的参数都开放给你，
你自己去挑参数，
然后自己去设置，
那么你可以做一些定向的，
比如说我要挑一个色温，
我要挑一个什么速度要慢一点的快门，
对吧，这种情况下你可以去使用，
但大多数情况下我都是用的拍照的就自动，
就纯自动，就傻瓜一样，按就行了，
现在我用的是7 Ultra，
它最多能够到8.6，
8.6其实相当于200，
然后它的画质它原生摄像头拍出来几乎是一样的，
所以说你的整个胶段的覆盖范围会很广，
还有一个很重要的一点，
手机拍照它有的时候识别主体会自动识别，
当你拍的东西有一个前景的时候，
它可能识别不到后面的东西，
所以这个时候我就切换到专业模式，
改成手动对焦，
就是我其他都不变，
我就是把切换到专业模式，
点击对焦，
点击对焦其实也不准，
当你前面有个书也有个玻璃的时候，
它可能就对到玻璃上面，
当你用手动对焦的时候，
它有风质显示，
其实它可能你平常用相机切换到的手动模式是一样的，
这样你对焦就会更准确，
你可以对到前面有个帘子的情况下，
后面人影的一个无体上面，
我觉得这个还是比较适用的，
然后我现在手机拍照大部分的修图，
基本上就是用相册自带的编辑功能，
是，我也是，
真的很好用，
是的,
而且去年更新了之后，
现在还有粘贴编辑点的功能，
就类似于我们在Lightroom里面的复制设置，
就是我把设置拷贝过来，
再复制到另外一张照片，
或者图部，
使用起来现在就很方便了，
就是我如果在修一组的过程中，
我只需要调一张图，
可以保持这组图的影调，
色调都统一是吗？
对，基本上就差不多统一，
然后你可能只需要粘贴过来之后，
再做一些微调就可以了，
所以我觉得这也是一个非常好用的，
当然它可能说没有Lightroom那么全面，
当然毕竟是一个手机版本的，
它可能还是有些功能，
没办法做得那么细致，
但是我觉得已经非常好用了。
我也是，
我觉得挺够用的，
我一般的习惯是，
我先选好我想修的那张照片，
我会先降低它的曝光，
然后拉亮它的亮度，
我喜欢把照片的饱和度，
稍微再降下来一点，
但不是直接去调整它的饱和度，
我觉得这点是我的一个经验。
直接调饱和度的话，
会让照片的颜色过度，
会有点奇怪。
是的,
因为低跑车照片相对来说，
更耐看一点。
其实我刚说了，
手机这么多功能，
其实我觉得还有一点是，
它最大的区别于相机的一个异点，
就是你可以马上就发，
好的,
然后我觉得有一点小Bug的地方，
是我在抓拍的时候，
如果我是用数码相机去抓拍的话，
我心里对这个结果是有，
比较有数的，
我大概能知道，
相机能拍出一个什么样的画面来，
但有时候手机去抓拍的时候，
它应该是算法的关系，
所以它这个物体，
不太会在你想要的位置，
我一直在拍一个，
就是那个高铁开过的时候，
外面树影的一些画面，
有时候我真的要拍好多张，
我可能才会得到一张比较满意的，
甚至有时候我觉得有点像在喷运气，
就是喷这个算法能算到，
我觉得好看的那一瞬间，是的。
相当于是算法，
它在很多帧当中给你选了一帧，
然后最终呈现出这一帧，
它认为就比较好的，比较清晰的，
但可能不是你想要的，
我也有这样的感受，
就是当拍一个远处的人的时候，
我往往会跟着他的脚步，
我一定要想要拍到他，
迈开大步往前走的那个瞬间，
因为如果两只脚叠在一起，
就会觉得很奇怪，
这可能是我个人的一个习惯吧，
如果我拍一个人物在我的画面里的话，
我都希望他的脚是分开的，
如果他在走，
他就带着动感的在走的，
我就这样觉得画面可能说会更生动一点。
我能理解，不是脚并起来的。
对，我相信就是，
每次得数着他的，
他马上卖下一步，按一下快门，
下一步按下快门，
就这样起来，
当然多按几张，
其实也会拍到自己想要的，
但不是每次都能得到比较理想的画面。
然后还有一个小的bug点，
就是我有时候用手机拍完照之后，
我没有一个意识去关掉他，
手机他可能摄像头还开着，
我就把它揣到兜里了，
然后有时候会发热，
然后还没到一天结束，
可能直到下午，
电量就只有百分之二十几，
然后那个时候我就会有点着急了，
所以说，
如果你也有说用手机拍照的这个习惯，
要注意一下，
有没有把这个显示品关掉，
不然他真的会一直在运作。
我在熊约古道图布完之后，
我每天晚上很累了，
我就很早就躺下了，
差不多是八九点，
就平时这个时候可能刚下班吃完饭，
但在熊约古道那几天，
基本上就是我躺在床上放松，
然后开始选照片，
我这个过程都要选到一个多小时的时间，
因为一天真的拍了很多照片，
那你选照片是怎么选的？
其实我在每一张拍了之后，
心里都会觉得说，
这张晚上可以一定要选出来，
其实当天拍的时候，
心里是稍微有点数的，
只是回去的时候再翻看一下，
就前后再做一个筛选，
然后再去调整他的颜色，
因为我喜欢稍微按掉一点的，
以及饱和度低一点的照片。
是的，因为你手机拍的照片，
其实在不加濾镜的情况下，
它还是比较鲜艳的，
整体来说比较鲜艳。
对了，正好赛文，
你说到濾镜，
你有在小米他自带的那些濾镜，
你有特别喜欢的吗？
我特别喜欢黑柔。
我特别喜欢白柔。
我喜欢白柔，我想黑柔。
对，就是会有一种很梦幻的感觉。
黑柔和白柔，
我觉得区别就是他的发光的地方，
而且白柔会更强烈，
白柔就是用高光的部分，
去做这种萌农的处理方式，
然后黑柔的发光会在那个地处上，
它是更弱化一点的，
它穿的就是没有那么强烈，
不是纯粹高光的部分，
所以它的效果会弱很多，
但是反而就是加了一点点，
就是刚刚好，我是会觉得。
对，就一点点，真的就一点点，
因为有时候它里面自带的濾镜，
还是挺强的，
就如果你那个条拉到100%，
你会觉得有点过，
我一般觉得喜欢的濾镜，
可能也就选到30%，
不太会50%，
我基本上就是，
我的修图顺序可以给大家分享一下，
我拍完，拍完之后我选图，
选图就是用信号，
收藏键，
然后我会全部每张照片都看一遍，
看一遍就是所有喜欢的都加收藏，
但是我不是所有照片都修，
就是我加完收藏之后，
我在到收藏夹里面，
就把刚刚加了新的照片再过一遍，
然后看到喜欢的，
我就在那里编辑，
编辑是这样的，
我是先进去，
会选一个滤镜，
试一遍之后，
觉得最喜欢的一个，
然后呢，
把它换到条件里面去，
首先就是拿下曲线，
我现在修图的习惯是喜欢比较柔和一点照片，
所以我会希望它的，
阴影部分，暗部分，
然后它这个对比是稍微弱一点的，
所以我会在曲线里面，
把我的阴影，
然后给提一提，
高光给拉下来，
把整个画面稍微的平一点，
会去对比度和亮度那里，
去把对比度和亮度，
稍微去微调一下，
调完这些之后，
再去调色彩，
色彩主要是调饱和度，
和某个单个色彩，
那你修的还挺深度的，
但有个问题就是，
目前来说，
它里面只有六种颜色，
就是,
它你能调的范围，
它就是不够细嘛，
所以说，
只能调，
我就不会调太多，
我就基本上，
如果是主色调，
或者主要是那种绿色，
或者天空，
就经常会出现的嘛，
就是绿色和天空，
这两个东西，
可能就会稍微把他们弱化一下，
可能也是根据照片风格吧，
来调,
那你调的还挺认真的，
基本上保存之后，
最后,
我会先保存一个副本，
然后再编辑，
再加一个水音，
你还别说，
小米的那个水音，
真的挺好看的，
那首先，
我有两个问题想问你，
第一个，
你会伤手机里的照片吗？
目前来说，
只有那种，
就一个是我使用连拍的时候，
连拍的时候，
它会是拍一组照片，
我需要对里面照片去筛选，
筛选然后其他都会删掉，
还有另外一种就是，
我会有明显的失误的照片，
或者是拍了一张，
就是觉得，
嗯,
其臭无比的，
如果是一些，
除了这两，
这两类照片之外，
其他那种比较正常的照片，
我会留着的，
一来是因为，
手机存储也很多嘛，
其实不会有，
就是一时半会儿去拍不满的，
然后另外一个就是，
我会有定期回看照片的，
我一个场景，
你可能说拍了几张，
因为我不是那种，
纯脸拍的形式，
就是从，
每个动作之间，
差别很微小的，
我可能说，
会有一些，
虚伪的就是，
角度上的变化，
或者说，
它被拍摄的对象，
它姿势啊，
或者说有些变化，
我会把它保留下来，
所以我在不同的时间，
去回看这些照片的时候，
可能你喜欢的又不一样，
所以我不会去删这些照片，
就没有没有删照片习惯，
你，你不经常删照片吗？
我也不太会，
我回想了一下，
但我是会担心，
说有一天，
车照片撮满了的话，
怎么办？
我是有这个担心，
然后还有一个问题，
就是,
就是这个水印问题，
我承认，
其实加个水印，
是挺好看的，
怎么说呢，
人家会觉得说，
哎呦,
我有朋友说，
哎呦，你买莱卡了，
他第一眼，
会先被这个标吸引，
我说，啊没有没有，
这是小米莱卡的手机，
对,
所以他有时候，
会成为一个照片，
那个抢眼的点，
嗯,
我大概理解你的意思，
其实我之前也讲过，
然后,
甚至会有的，
有的时候会想，
就是,
我加一个手机，
手机的水印，
会不会给人一种感觉，
我好像是在，
在展示说，
啊,
你用手机拍的，
都拍的这么，
拍的好，
或者怎么样，
好像是显示，
你很厉害，
但是我后面是，
接受了一个接车，
是因为，
因为大家，
就有这样的需求，
你想现在，
像我没有的时候，
也会自己相机拍照片，
也会加一些水印，
加一些框，
就是未来是说，
我可能告诉大家，
这个,
照片的一些信息，
一些参数，
另外一方面，
其实说，
比较严肃的场合，
我还是更倾向于，
用没有水印的照片，
但是我最在这种，
分享的场合，
我觉得，
好的水印设计，
让我觉得很舒服，
我觉得我，
我,
我是愿意去使用的，
我甚至还可能，
减少了一些麻烦，
别人说，
都不用告诉他，
你自己开水印，
就知道是手机拍的，
所以我就觉得，
我是愿意使用的，
嗯,
我用了水印之后，
我发了那个，
小红书码，
会有人留言说，
哎呦,
你这个是用14拍的，
比我17拍的还好，
但我其实，
我就不太希望，
别人关注，
这个到底是用14，
还是17拍的，
然后这个是一点，
还有一点就是，
比如说，
我拍了一系列的照片，
但是,
其中的某一张，
正好,
比如说，
处于下半部分，
画面的信息，
我其实不太希望，
有水印的出现，
但是你一组照片里面，
突然有一张，
没有水印，
又很奇怪，
然后我就会，
去考虑说，
哎呦,
那要不都给他，
换一个位置，
都把它换到，
比如说，
右下角，
因为它右下角，
也是一个选项，
所以有时候，
加不加水印，
也会成为一个，
后期中，
我以前，
不太会，
纠结的点，
我也有那种，
混发的，
就是,
有加水印，
你觉得这张照片，
开心,
而且有的时候，
确实,
它就有点像射景，
你知道吗，
我如果是一张，
纯粹的照片，
当然它这张照片，
是好干的，
但我加上，
这个水印之后，
它会变得，
好像,
更好看了一点，
其实这个东西，
我觉得是，
它就对，
它就是有一种，
它有道理的，
对，它是有一点道理，
但是我在突然，
想到说，
如果我用，
苹果手机拍的照片，
我就不会，
在照片上，
再加一个，
苹果的logo，
我以前专门，
用第三方的APP，
加苹果的那个，
比如我用的，
iPhone14 Pro,。
然后开机，
就,
其实我觉得，
就无所谓，
确实我觉得，
我同意，
你就说，
如果在有些，
分享的社交场合，
比如说，
像小红书，
我觉得加一加，
可以上照片，
感到怎么说呢，
有点,
智感上的提高吧，
我觉得，
是水印的作用吧，
就好像更高级了一点，
因为,
它,
好像更高级，
对,
因为它，
变成了一个摄影作品，
而是一个摄影作品，
搭配了一个好的设计，
没说的很多，
一个设计感出来的，
对,
也可以这样理解，
它其实就是，
对你的照片，
进行了一个，
再包装，
就是,
我们,
把照片，
看作一个产品的话，
它其实就是，
对这产品，
做了一个包装设计，
其实也会有一些别的作用，
就是说，
我加了水印之后，
有的水印，
是可以，
把你做的名字，
也加上去的，
其实是有一定的，
防盗图，
现在,
AI技术很发达，
想去个水印很简单，
但毕竟，
它还是有成本的，
还是需要时间去做的，
那塞文，
你会更喜欢，
莱卡经典，
还是莱卡生动呢？
我会更喜欢，
经典一点，
因为我比较喜欢，
在,
就是,
阳光明媚的天气拍照，
所以,
生动就会把整个的，
饱和度，
搭的比较多，
所以说，
我不太喜欢，
特别饱和的东西，
我跟你一样，
对的,
所以有的时候，
拍着拍着，
这个饱和这么高，
我就觉得，
我就知道，
肯定是，
设置上，
哪里有点问题，
我就会把它换过来，
那我从，
省约古到回来之后，
我又发现，
我其实，
用小米手机的，
频率又下来了，
我觉得，
其实,
究其原因还是，
因为我只喜欢，
习惯,
一台手机，
在手里，
或者说，
在口袋里，
虽然其实，
我现在尽量，
说我出门都带着，
但,
真的掏出来，
使用的场景，
还是比较少的，
那我就，
有另外一个问题，
想问三文，
就是,
像你就，
其实已经习惯了，
带着苹果手机，
你会觉得，
换来换去，
麻烦吗？
最开始的时候，
会不习惯的，
我最开始的时候，
我还会想，
哎呀，最近，
用苹果拍的照片，
都少了，
感觉好像，
有点对不起，
苹果的样子，
然后其实，
到后面，
我尤其是，
像我这次出去，
我发现，
我几乎不用，
苹果拍照，
我用苹果拍照的，
尝尝你是什么，
看到有一个东西，
我要发给别人，
要分享，
不是那种，
美图式的分享，
而是,
我要把这个东西，
分享出去，
或者把我看到的，
一个有意思的东西，
分享出去的时候，
我就用苹果手机拍，
拍完之后，
直接微信，
就发出去了，
因为我的微信，
都在苹果上面，
只有在这种情况下，
我才会用苹果拍照，
其他时间，
就像那是，
已经默认的，
我是拍照，
用另外一台，
然后,
就像那是，
一个是生活，
一个是创作，
大概他们这样，
分得很开的样子，
就不会觉得难受，
可能是因为我，
我已经习惯，
这样的方式很久了，
而且我，
还比较，
比较喜欢的一点，
就是我，
有的时候，
我去到一个地方，
我拍完照片之后，
我甚至都不需要，
捅不到我这个手机上面，
我都可以去，
发一些社交媒体，
我都可以，
那其他的像极客，
小公说什么，
我都可以，
直接在另外一个手机上发，
我觉得，
他的及时性非常好，
对，你说到这个，
就是我在熊也古道的时候，
每天晚上就很早，
就躺着休息了嘛，
然后我就在那边，
选图修图，
然后,
我的朋友，
他也在等我的照片，
我就觉得，
可以当天就发给他了，
不像,
我一般，
如果大家看到我发照片，
比如说去哪里玩了，
其实这个事情，
可能都是，
几周之前的事情了，
是的,
可以说是第一次，
把体验到了，
当天出土的快感，
但是我觉得，
这个,
这个是一个双人剑，
有好有坏，
好，就是说，
当天出土真的很爽，
是的,
我可以拍一些照，
拍了，修了之后，
我就发出来，
我就可以，
丢在群里，
或者丢到朋友圈，
给大家看，
啊，我干了什么，
就是这种分享率，
会被激发出来，
如果你用照片拍照，
可能拍完之后，
等你他洗出来，
已经是，
两个星期，
或者一个月之后了，
那当时你在发的时候，
其实你发的，
并不是，
你想分享这个照片，
并分享你干的什么，
你去哪里，
而是分享你的作品，
而当如果你用手机，
去拍照的时候，
你当天拍完，
就发的时候，
你其实有很大一部分，
是分享，
分享的是一个快感，
对，分享我的，
我的在场感，
今天,
此时此地，
我就在，
比如我在熊野古道，
我就想把这部分，
快乐分享出去，
它其实，
这两种分享，
其实,
对，都是分享，
是完全不一样的，
那然后，
我觉得另外一个弊端，
就是说，
我发完了之后，
我其实很少会回看，
对，我觉得，
就是如果，
我拍照片的时候，
我可能过了，
两三周，
或者一个月之后，
才拿到图，
我又可以把这份，
开心又，
等于说，
又回顾一遍，
那像手机的话，
我可能也会，
看一下相册，
但我,
好像跟当时的那种，
连接就少了一些，
可能那部分的快乐，
在当天，
就已经被用掉了，
也许要，
再隔一段时间，
再去看那些照片的时候，
才可能去重新建立，
就当时拍照的一些，
瞬间的感受。
我真有个建议，
但可能是我，
我自己的一些想法，
不一定适合你，
但我觉得你可以听一听，
就是,
你可以把，
手机拍摄的照片，
当作是，
相机拍摄的照片，
一样去处理，
比如说你，
相机拍摄照片，
隔几天再处理，对吧？
对，你需要对它编辑，
你需要对它存打，
需要备份，
因为有一个问题，
就是,
手机太方便了，
可能说，
你对待照片，
对待手机拍的照片，
你会天然带着，
有一种，
可能更随意的感觉，
你会,
你会可能会忽视它们，
但它们其实，
也会记录你，
某些时刻的，
那些旅程也好，
也不是，
好玩的东西也好，
它们其实，
也是很有意思的，
我觉得照片，
可能会因为，
拍摄工具，
会产生差异，
但是照片所存在的东西，
它是,
相同的，
它都会，
存在你的记忆，
存在你的回忆，
所以我觉得，
就是,
稍微更正式一点的，
去对待它们，
你可以定区去，
备份你的照片，
定区把一些，
你喜欢的照片，
存当起来，
然后,
你开定区去回看，
你可能也会，
获得,
相同的感觉，
我只是，
一个想法，
不过你说这话，
确实,
因为我在行为古道，
就是,
每天很累了，
基本上都是，
洗完澡，
换上了睡衣，
躺在床上，
开始,
弄照片，
你如果，
如果认真的去看的话，
或者是，
你就按照你，
拍照的那种，
习惯去处理这照片的话，
它一样是会，
有很多很好的照片，
很好的瞬间，
然后,
也会在你，
每次翻看的时候，
也会觉得很有意思，
嗯,
我又想到了，
一个，手机摄影的，
好处就是，
它非常的隐蔽，
嗯,
我记得我在那个，
京腔鱼市场，
我当时就，
用手机，
在东排排，
西排排，
但其实我心里，
会有点慌，
我会担心被驱赶，
哦对,
我知道，
市场挺感兴趣的，
我就好好玩，
它是可以随便去的吗？
对,
它是可以随便去的，
它,
那个地方叫，
记忆圣谱，
除了休息日，
它每天早上都会在，
它码头有一块区域，
把当天，
捕捞上来的京腔鱼，
一条一条的摊在地上，
会联系可能，
附近的一些商贩，
的,
比如说老板，
老板会到现场，
来选购，
京腔鱼，
然后,
可能好的京腔鱼，
大家会拍卖，
谁出的价钱高，
就把京腔鱼拖走了，
卖鱼这件事情，
和国内这种卖鱼，
好像又不太一样，
它特别的，
虽然就是很多鱼，
但是感觉很整齐，
摆得很整齐，
因为它都是京腔鱼，
都差不多大，
有些会特别大，
基本上是，
平铺在地上，
地上有个电子，
然后会有水，
一直冲着它们，
然后这个时候，
如果说我，
我觉得我拿着相机，
其实我会担心，
会被驱赶，
说，哎，这里，
不允许拍照，
啥啥,
你有没有得到认可吗？
那如果这个时候，
你拿着手机，
我就可以很，
理所当然的，
我也装成自己，
是一个游客，
觉得好奇，
在这边拍，
手机的隐蔽性，
是它的一个，
非常大的优点，
因为人人都有手机，
大家都可以，
都会拿着手机，
随便拍一点，
但这个鱼是，
还是挺好玩的，
挺值得去，
一定要早起，
回到刚刚的问题，
其实,
就是在手机拍照，
它就,
没有一个攻击性嘛，
就是像，
我在跟别人拍照的时候，
即便是拍肖像，
就是,
我说给的，
就是给它拍张照，
当我背着一个相机的时候，
它们其实是，
会默认的，
会,
有点防范，
或者是，
比较警惕这件事情，
所以我觉得，
手机,
在一些，
场景里面，
确实,
能帮助我们，
拍到一些，
有意思的画面。
而且,
手机有个很重要的功能，
就是,
Live photo,。
对,
但我,
我会把这两个事情，
分得很开，
拍,
photo,
可以这样讲，
我是分开的，
就是,
Live就是,
我会觉得一些，
有趣的动的瞬间，
我会拍成Live，
但其实，
今年拍的很少，
我更多还是在拍photo，
我还是在拍，
静止的图像，
我觉得最主要，
我不喜欢拍Live的原因，
是因为，
Live图,
除了手针之外，
它整个画质太差了，
这是我觉得，
我接受不了的原因，
就是,
你一旦播放起来，
它其实是画质很差的，
我觉得还挺有趣的，
我觉得，
Live photo,。
可能在苹果上，
会运用的更多，
虽然我，
我苹果默认的，
也是拍Live photo,。
但是我，
基本上不用苹果拍照，
现在,
但是我，
其实,
确实忍受不了，
就是Live photo,。
里面,
虽然你把它，
是为它封面之后，
它是会清晰，
但是,
它整个播放的过程，
它就不是清晰的，
它就是会比，
就是,
你要么拍video，
对吧,
就要么拍静止的画面，
就是Live photo,。
有点,
不左不右，
可能,
可能这是我不太，
不是特别喜欢，
如果它画质好一点，
如果它做到，
就是像那时，
我只是，
类似于拍视频一样，
它只是一段，
然后每一阵都比较清晰，
画质是稳定的，
那我可能会比较喜欢。
我是这么觉得啊，
就是,
嗯，拍video的话，
它确实很倾向于，
一段时间，
比如说，
10秒,
20秒,30秒,。
它会记录，
一长段的，
这个动态的影像，
但我,
还挺少去回看的，
但像苹果手机里面，
有时候你长按屏幕，
它会稍微播放一段，
它可以让，
让我的回忆，
更立体一点，
它有前后，
有声音，
有前后，
有这一秒钟，
两，甚至两秒钟的，
一个动态，
我可能，
不会特别在意，
画面的清晰度，
这个我可以理解，
就相当于是，
它相当于是，
介于静态影像，
和动态视频之间的，
以一种，
记录方式，
我觉得，
它的真实感，
会增加，
就像,
比如说，
小红树有，
如果有个标题，
写Live图,
那我会觉得，
它描述的这件事情，
可能这种，
真实感，
会更强一点，
这个词学的很好，
Live图,
对呀,
它但凡标题里，
有一点，
我可能就点开进去，
看看是咋回事，
这确实是，
让我们的，
拍的东西，
比起一点，
其实我这里，
就有一个问题，
现在有太多，
太多,
以打卡的，
就是去到一个地方，
最重要的，
不再是，
说我感受到了什么，
我体验了什么，
而是,
朋友圈，
就是为了，
就是我一定要发一个，
很精壮的朋友圈，
才能算说，
我的旅行成功的，
就是有的时候，
就感觉好像，
我们是为了拍照去旅行，
而不是为了，
不是因为旅行，
好玩,
在拍照，
我最近想的，
一个话题就是，
可能只有旅行的时候，
就是会让你，
拍照的冲动，
会更强，
就像我们之前，
说到过一个，
内区还是，
外区,
我就想，
平时,
我平时，
可能就上下班，
就加到，
上班的地方，
两点一线，
可能,
下了半天，
就很晚了，
也很饿，
就想回去休息，
就这种状态下，
可能没有一个，
很轻松的时光，
留给我去，
拍照,
但旅行，
它就是，
涵盖了一个出行，
一个,
被很多新鲜的，
未知事物，
包裹的，
这样的一个，
场景,
一个环境，
那这样一段，
出行的时光，
相比于，
我平时这种，
上下班，
非常固定的，
来说是一个，
怎么说，
是一个次点吧，
生活里的一个次点，
所以,
会想要去，
记录它，
其实是因为，
旅行,
所以在拍照，
不是因为我，
为了拍照而旅行，
可以这样理解吗？
或者也说，
就比如说，
我休息日出去拍照，
或者说，
我为了，
一个项目而拍照，
也会拍，
那比如说，
明天我休息了，
我可能出去，
散个步的时候，
也会可能，
在走路的时候，
按几张，
但也不会那么，
隆重的去发出来，
就是,
可发可不发，
但旅行的时候，
是一个，
比较高浓度的，
新鲜的，
外在刺激，
就有很多，
一个集合，
没有见过的，
新的人，
新的事物，
然后天气又很好，
用漂亮的东西，
就会这样，
就如果说，
你让我，
比如说，
天天在熊也骨到，
我可能也就不会发了，
就你就这样去假设，
然后你刚才又说到，
一个打卡，
怎么说呢？
其实金枪鱼市场，
也算是一个打卡，
它其实，
之前,
小红书装，
也有很多人，
抛出来过了，
一个人旅行的时间，
可能真的是很短的，
你期望，
你在这么短的时间里，
不要有太多的错误，
我觉得可能是因为这个点，
就如果说，
我有一个月，
两个月，
在这个城市，
那我可能就不会去，
刻意的去，
这里,
我也要拍那边，
我也要拍，
我可能会相对，
就更轻松一点，
但我只有一天，
或者两天，
就在这个地方，
那我,
可能为了自己，
不要太出错，
就势必会去一些，
闷闷一点的地方，
可能是因为我，
其实,
最近几年，
好久不上班了，
也处于这种，
就是,
我有很多时间，
可以到一个地方去，
去体验，
你刚刚这样讲的，
这我是能够理解的，
嗯,
但是,
我们这次，
熊月谷道里，
也有一天，
就是我，
同行的小伙伴，
他的Pokey的3，
丢了,
所以我们，
就是,
本来要到下一个，
图布点，
要准备开始，
图布了，
他要准备把Pokey3，
好像,
丢在那个地方，
然后,
我们纠结了一下之后，
我们就打算，
回到之前的，
那个,
一个神，
神社里，
对,
一个神社里，
去找找看，
那这样，
其实就势必耽误了，
我们那一天的，
图布的行程，
其实那一天，
有一段的路，
我们其实没有走，
我们走了，
其他的地方，
那我觉得，
像这种，
突发情况，
就,
你可能这一段，
你就走不了了，
你也拍不了，
这一段的照片了，
谢谢,
反正,
我们接下来，
就换了一条路，
可能他没有那么知名，
就没有，
很多,
大家容易出片的，
好的风景，
但,
我觉得，
就是摄影人，
如果你是一个，
喜欢拍照的，
只要有一个，
还不错的风景，
不管怎么样，
你都能，
看到,
属于你自己的视角，
就算他，
我接下来走，
走回神社的那段路，
他不是一个风景区，
但你热爱观察，
就这段路，
这段旅程，
还是属于你的，
你不要担心，
说,
哎呀,
我这段不完了，怎么办？
对，很有道理，
就是说，
好的记录，
其实,
有的时候，
并不是说，
你真正的去了，
一些多么壮丽，
多么,
多么宏大的一些地方，
反而就是说，
你自己带入了，
你的个人视角，
到你的生活，
到你的旅行当中，
你记录了一段，
读属于你个人的旅行，
这种,
我觉得，
就是,
很好的，
以及我想到旅行中，
会有很多遗憾，
以及这些遗憾，
我们都会说，
哎呀,
没关系，
下次再来吧，
但是,
其实回想一下，
都不太会，
真的下次再去了，
这还好吧，
说的怎么突然，
变得这么，
这么伤感呢？
不伤感，
我觉得，
这个事件，
很客观的事情，
就比如说，
我在山西，
我有一个胶片，
我设置错了，
然后导致，
我那三四卷，
其实拍的，
基本上都是费的，
就是麻米亚，
潘福的套件，
然后,
他,
为了能拍，
135,
他其实，
在取景框里面，
装了个档片，
他可以拍中间那一条，
但我后来，
我要切换的时候，
我忘记，
把那个档片拿走了，
我继续装，
120的卷,
那就等于，
我120的那卷，
就只能拍到，
中间那一条的画面，
上下其实都拍不到，
拍了大概，
四五卷的120，
就,
中间都是，
只有那一条画面，
所以我当时，
就,
也难受，
然后,
同行的人就说，
没关系的，
反正下次再来嘛，
山西又不是国外，
你还可以去，
但我知道，
可能,
今年也不太会再去了，
明年又谁知道呢，
以后又谁知道呢，
但是,
去了之后，
比如说，
这里这个景，
或者,
这个楼，
可能也不是拍到的那个样子了，
嗯,
但,
你要想，
其实,
事物都在发生变化，
我们不可能说，
你这次错过了，
下次去的时候，
过去会有更新的风景，
或者更有不一样的风景，
更不一样的区域在下来，
是的，是的，
对,
拥抱未知嘛，
我觉得未知，
反而挺有意思的，
嗯,
有时候在旅行当中去，
给自己的旅行，
带来一点不确定性，
不确定性，
或者是不确定感，
反而我觉得，
可能会让你的旅行，
变得,
不一样一点，
当然,
这种不确定感，
可能是，
也有可能变成一些，
相对来说，
没那么，
没那么正向的，
可能有的时候，
会多很多烦恼，
你自己变得很疲惫，
但是,
恰恰是因为，
那一点点烦恼，
或者绕了一段远路，
那一些疲惫，
而变得更，
记忆深刻，
你可能在，
很久很久很久之后，
都还能记得，
就是,
旅程,
确实就有些路，
就走，就走那么一次，
是的,
好,
那我们还是说回到摄影，
那你下一次，
还是,
只带手机嘛，
我接下来一段旅程，
应该要去法国，
哦,
先是一段时间的出差，
我要去法国的农场，
看人家做奶酪，
啊,
你这工作好快乐啊，
然后,
我计划，
嗯,
会带一个手机，
然后,
我会带一台，
李光,
嗯,
可能还是会带一下，
然后,
会带一台路来，
哦,
那你带的也不少，
嗯,
但我觉得，
像一些重要的，
场合,
重要的一些人文场合，
我可能会，
用胶片去排，
嗯,
这部分，
比如说，
你要赶路，
有时候需要一些，
长焦的情况，
我觉得，
手机确实是一个，
很好的，
摄影工具了，
而且,
你可以拍完就发，
分享一些，
就是我们的听诱，
或者是，
关注你的一些人，
去分享你的一些动态，
我觉得，
这种是比较，
比较,
还是比较好玩的，
而且现在的手机场上，
都有一些，
自己的，
影像比赛，
或者投稿，
嗯,
它也会让你，
激发你一些，
去创作的动力，
现在我感觉，
手机的比赛，
比,
相机的都多，
至少国内是这样的，
嗯,
当然每个，
每个品牌，
它可能有自己，
不同的，
就是,
审美倾向，
嗯,
但我觉得，
就是你可能说，
你喜欢什么，
然后你先，
拍到什么照片，
适合去投，
我觉得，
都可以去尝试一下，
不管说，
你能不能获奖，
获奖的，
我觉得，
那当然是好事，
如果没获奖的话，
其实,
你想想去，
他们到底好在哪里，
我是觉得，
这些还是，
对自己，
如果你真的，
喜欢拍照的话，
还是很有帮助的，
真的有的时候，
我能看，
能理解到，
哦,
原来手机，
能拍这样的东西，
可能,
以前就没想过，
我也是看了，
这一两年的，
大赛里面，
大家,
提交的一个，
作品,
原来,
其实手机摄影的，
应用范围，
真的还挺大的，
比我想像中，
大很多，
是的,
但,
这些场景，
我觉得，
这台手机给我妈，
我妈是绝对，
可能拍不出那些，
那些很牛的一些大作，
其实,
你要想，
它并不在于是手机，
还是相机，
就是你把一个相机，
交给一个，
就是说，
它没有经过专业训练的人，
它可能，
是的,
对,
它可能拍的东西，
也拍不出，
对,
所以,
它更多还是你的视角，
只是说，
手机它只是作为一个器材，
而且这个器材，
越方便，
越来越好用，
越来越，
厉害,
就像现在，
手机的市场和，
相机的市场简直，
就是,
对比选输，
现在大家都用手机拍照了，
很,
就是相机的，
就是,
还是作为一个，
更专业的工具，
而且,
是一个更专业，
沉重,
还有很强的，
使用成本的工具，
你需要去学习，
对吧,
然后你，
手机不需要，
我只要打开，
我只要打开相机这个APP，
我按快码就行了，
谁还不会去，
那个点呢？
是的,
就是,
我们可以预见到的，
手机会越来越方便，
越来越好用，
但是,
我觉得，
拍照有一个，
很本质的问题，
就是你，
观看的方式，
我觉得，
我,
就是,
这几年，
在摄影上，
进步还是挺大的，
挺大的，
很厉害，
我觉得就是，
和以前拍的东西，
就是,
差别特别大，
你能放到一起的话，
你说的以前是什么，
对，我刚认识你的时候，
那你先说说，
你觉得我差别，
差在哪里？
就是,
以前我会觉得，
更像是，
大众都会拍的一种方式，
我会拍一些，
猫啊,
或者拍一些，
那种人物扫街的那种场景，
而现在，
就是,
更关注的是，
我为什么要拍？
我感觉，
这个是，
从画面，
你能看得出来的一些变化，
比如我看到，
你拍的一些，
关于在上海的，
街头的一些，
就是场景性的，
真的是你，
以前是看不到的，
现在看得到了，
对，真的，
对,
所以我觉得，
摄影就是一个，
看到的过程，
那你觉得像，
数码像，
即胶片像，
即这种，
比较笨重的，
比较大的，
比较严肃的机器，
和像一个手机，
他们在拍这方式上，
对你来说，
区别大吗？
对我来说，
区别还是蛮大的，
那我当然，
我也会用手机，
去拍一些像，
用相机才会拍的照片，
比如说一些，
场景性的，
或者是一些，
偏肖像类的，
就是,
比较严肃肖像，对吧，
但是,
但是你和用，
相机的时候的，
感觉是不一样的，
因为相机天然，
我会觉得，
它会有一个，
体积也好，
它的,
重量也好，
它会带来一种意识感，
拍摄的，
如果是一个人物的话，
它也会有这样的感受，
所以它在对待相机，
和你拿手机去拍那时候，
它的感受也是不一样，
当然我说，
在观察方式上，
我觉得两个并没有，
就说你拿到相机，
你也,
拿到手机，
你也可以完全，
按照相机的方式去拍，
你观察，
因为你，
你同样是做在观察，
它其实都是一个观察的结果，
只是说，
我觉得手机，
可以拍的东西会更多，
因为它的，
它具有很多，
就像我们刚刚谈过的，
它会有很大的隐蔽性，
然后也没有攻击性，
所以它会拍的东西，
会更不一样一点，
其实对我来说，
我觉得工具都是，
次要的，
还是说你的视角，
有时候你的主题，
某些主题，
更适合用手机，
有的主题，
更适合用相机，
它只是你选择，
但并不代表说，
你的手机就不能拍，
相机那样的照片，
或者相机就不能拍，
手机那样的照片，
我觉得，
这只是，
没有那么觉得的事情，
是,
我也是，
就是,
我觉得，
用相机，
带给我的一些观察习惯，
其实会延伸到用手机上，
它特别方便，
尤其在一些你，
偶然发生的事情，
当中,
你甚至来不及套相机，
一个跑过去的小孩，
我记得我之前，
在上海拍过一张照片，
在那个，
一个桥下面，
忘了什么桥了，
就是当时一个很可爱的，
好像是个混血，
还是一个外国小女孩，
她背上背着一个翅膀，
穿着一个粉色的小裙子，
很可爱的超我冲过来，
但是我当时手里拿的是一个，
半幅的，
那个索尼的相机，
配的是一个手动头，
它向我冲过来的时候，
我虽然用镜头对准了它，
但是我完全对不上角，
就是那一刻太快了，
就根本来不及记录，
但我在想，
如果我当时掏出的是手机的话，
我肯定就把这个拍下来，
当然我最终是拍下来，
一张虚了的照片，
但是,
就像在那个瞬间还是，
也很美好，
对，很美好，
然后如果说，
你再想，
如果当时人打手机拍的话，
可能拍的会，
更好一点，
嗯,
我这几年有一个，
讲法上的转变，
就是我之前觉得，
拍虚的照片，
或者说，
主体是虚的照片，
对我当时的来说，
可能这个照片，
就好像拍失败了，
嗯,
但如果说，
你是根据整体氛围而选择，
或者说，
哪怕你失误了，
但是,
这张虚掉的照片，
依然很有意境的话，
它依然是一张好的照片，
但以前我就意识不到，
我昨天在一个博物馆里面，
我再拍一个坐在椅子上的人，
当我刚把那个，
按快捕那一瞬间，
它起来了，
然后它起来的那一瞬间，
我就,
下一时的就，
也跟着它抖了，
然后就拍出了一个，
就很抽象的东西，
重影吗？
没有重影，
人都看不到了，
但就是一个场景抽象，
但是因为它里面有，
有那种光源，
你会去猜测，
这东西到底是什么，
我把其他的一些，
我本身就拍的一些，
抽象的东西放在一起的时候，
反而我觉得，
就是,
它能够形成一些联系，
比你那种，
微作拍的一张，
非常标准的，
曝光也好，
很清晰的照片，
反而更有意思，
看你怎么利用吧，
有的时候，
一相费片，
它在一些合适的位置，
反而用，
会比一张，
清晰完美的照片，
更有意思，
是，手机在，
很多场景下，
都会显得灵活，
但我觉得，
这个应该也同样，
比如说，
适用于像李光，
这样小巧，
轻便的机器，
它这不同的形态吗？
嗯,
好，我今天和白熊聊了，
很多关于，
手机剩意的话题，
如何使用手机，
然后它的一些便利性，
其实我们，
我想对于，
现在的人来说，
手机剩意，
一个绕不开的话题，
不管是说，
你会拍照，
或者不会拍照，
大家都会用手机去记录，
我觉得记录这件事情，
本身就是，
很有意义的，
当然,
如果你在记录的同时，
加上一点自己的想法，
或者,
再加上一些自己的视角，
它会变得更有意思，
如果你再加上一些，
很新奇的旅程，
很新奇的记忆在里面，
它会变成一个，
读属于你自己一个，
个人的记忆。
今天节目就到此为止，
感谢各位收听。
欢迎大家加入我们的社群，
跟我们一起聊摄影。
下期节目再见，
拜拜。